I'm go
a good time
I'm the walk that
Oh
you may have awesome crazy stuff cuz
anethe the world of fallout 4 is growing
by the day
and while I'm going to be talking about
my top 5 favorite PC mods right now by
this time next month my list could be
completely different for us the players
this is an excellent problem to have
there's hundreds of awesome mods and
dozens more coming constantly but if you
install them all your game is just going
to implode which is why I'm here to give
you a radioactive recommendation of what
I think are some of the best starting
off with things that go boom this mod is
actually a pack of weapon mods by doom
the pack contains a total of 10 weapons
with dozens of attachments that fit
excellently into the world of Fallout 4
shotguns machine guns carbines assault
rifles pistols and even a recreation of
that gun from Blade Runner and Fallout
New Vegas all the weapons are fully
customizable so you can alter them to
your needs and they have all been
balanced and added to in-game level
tables so you don't have to worry about
being too overpowered or a sneaky radar
blowing you in half with some of these
weapons my personal favorite the big 10
is the modular collage rifle based on
the real world aka 47 and barring a
similar resemblance to the Chinese
assault rifle from previous Fallout
games and while this is a list of the
best PC mods it's also available in
console you lucky lucky Devils if you
find the sellers around your towns
aren't up to scratch well you can always
remove the human element workshop say
the production allows you to create your
own autonomous comrades or even just
fill an entire settlement with mammal
movies the machine itself is the same
piece of hardware that you'll come
across at the Institute so make sure
your settlement can accommodate a piece
of tech this size to create a synth you
need six batches of synth tissue twelve
bone and one modified synth component
per sailor created and then you can just
sit back and watch the miracle of life
happen right before your eyes
and then of course assign them some
tedious tasks but they're robots they
don't care
we're the edition of the fallout 4
creation kit we started to get some
awesome quests and adventure mods and
welcome to good neighbour is one of the
best this mod adds over 500 lines of
dialogue and takes about two to three
hours to complete the package also
includes two story missions three
assassination missions seven new
establishments two player homes new
locations of the Commonwealth and new
enemies items and more I always enjoy
mods that let you explore other people's
awesome adventures and this one comes
fully fledged with its own bank heist
good neighbor was also one of the cooler
areas in the Commonwealth so it's great
to see it get expanded on by talented
modders if you're looking for an extra
adventure after getting through all the
DLCs main quests well then this is your
mod home maker expanded settlements by
Nova Carew adds a huge amount of
resources to the settlement system
there's over 1000 objects to craft and
add to your settlement everything from
refrigerators motorbikes house plans
lamps concrete walls synthetic beds and
everything in between after building a
dozen fully fleshed settlements they do
start to feel like they all look the
same
made of wood and rust this mod however
allows you to add some variants to your
settlers homes you can build anything
from Institute related settlements to
raid a themed or even just use the 1000
new pieces to supplement stuff you've
already built but these extra bits and
bobs are in an interior designer can
decorate to their heart's content and
make your own little irradiated home
away from home
the armorsmith extended mod does a huge
amount the clothing system in fallout 4
too much to even cover in this video it
vastly improves how pieces of armour and
clothing work together enables
combinations of armor clothing base wear
and helmets that weren't possible before
it also makes every piece of clothing an
armor fully multiple there's new
craftable pieces of clothing glasses
gloves and whole new pieces of attire
for you your companions and your canine
comrade soon enough you and your
companions will be walking the red
carpet or the strangely green glowing
carpet so those are my 5 picks for PC
mods in fallout 4 if you've been using
mods yourself you no doubt have your
favourites so make sure you leave them
in the comment section below or tweet
them at me using the hashtag GS fallout
and I'll be sure to check them out until
next time make sure you like the video
subscribe and stay tuned for GameSpot
for everything irradiated